[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory for today's video
i wanted to do something a little bit
different than normal i do a lot of
explanations and theories
and things like that but for today i
wanted to share with you
my own thoughts on what i would like to
see in an ideal world
coming out of the harry potter film
franchise over the next years
decades when the last book was released
there was certainly a sense of finality
when it came to the harry potter series
however fortunately the films were
lagging behind which meant that they
were able to keep the same magic alive
for a few more years however when the
deathly hallows finally ended
i didn't really know what to watch next
so i did what any other sane harry
potter fan would do
i started the films and books again from
the beginning we're now in 2020
which means that it's been 13 years
since the last book came out
and nine years since the last movie came
out which effectively means that i've
now repeated this
rereading re-watching process more time
than i care to admit
with fans longing for more magical harry
potter related content
jk rowling and warner brothers answered
with fantastic beasts somewhere to find
them
which came out in 2016. the film had
varying reviews
and though it was a far cry from the
harry potter films that i so knew and
loved
i appreciated the effort i thought it
was an okay movie certainly not
comparable to the franchise from which
it was based
but did a decent job as far as a prequel
goes then
just two short years later fantastic
beasts the crimes of grindelwald was
released
in 2018. this film in my opinion did a
better job of tying in the magical world
that we already knew and loved
i think that the fan reception of the
first film was clear give us more of
what we know
and love we want new but maybe not
everything
what this meant for the film was more
connections to the harry potter world in
the form of characters
places creatures and references we even
got to see dumbledore
unfortunately it's now november 2020 and
i say unfortunately because november
2020 is when fantastic beasts 3 was
originally
supposed to be released however it has
clearly not been released
in fact we're now looking at a summer
release date this is for a number of
reasons a total screenplay rewrite
which is a plus covered delays and now
the recasting of the primary antagonist
johnny depp gaelic grindelwald with that
said many fans are upset with the way
that the harry potter franchise has been
handled
i'm happy with fantastic beasts and i'm
really interested to see where they go
with it
now that more time and effort has been
allocated toward the film
however one thing that i've always
thought is that rather than making
prequels to the harry potter films
and follow entirely different characters
why couldn't warner brothers have
pursued something that was
different but still familiar i am of
course talking about spin-offs that
follow
origin stories of characters that we
know and love spin-offs that discuss how
the wizarding world that we know
came to be the way that it is fantastic
beasts sort of does this
but still feels like it's independent
from the harry potter films in a lot of
ways
here are some of the films that i'd like
to see first of all an origin story for
the marauders
the marauders were a group of
mischievous young boys who attended
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry
during the 1970s these four boys were
characters that you've probably heard of
james potter sirius black remus lupin
and peter pettigrew
the quartet of boys began their studies
in 1971 the same year as severus snape
and they all had one thing in common
they were all gryffindors before the
sorting ceremony even happened
the boys hit it off and when they were
eventually sorted into the same house
they knew that they were destined to be
friends though the boys got on one to
many of their other classmates this
particular group of four boys
had a truly special bond and they
eventually came up with a name for their
group
they were the marauders the boys had a
lot in common beyond the fact that all
of them were gryffindors as they all
also happened to be huge troublemakers
if there was a rule at hogwarts they
were hell-bent on breaking it and they
were truly notorious for their rule
breaking
and mischief making their group existed
for the duration of the time that they
spent at hogwarts from 1971
to 1978 and after graduating they even
all went on to join the order of the
phoenix
a secret society founded by dumbledore
that opposed lord voldemort
this is a group of four characters that
are integral to the harry potter story
that already have a pre-established
backstory that could easily be adapted
into an independent narrative
james is the father of the boy who lived
sirius black is the man who lost his
friends
and basically his entire life in one
fateful night lupin is the boy who was
bitten by the notorious werewolf fenway
greyback
and pettigrew is the sniveling excuse
for a man that went down a very dark
path
these are four massive characters and i
think that i certainly speak for other
fans as well when i say
make this film the next spin-off that
i'd like to see
involves the four hogwarts founders and
the founding of the school itself
hogwarts goes with harry potter like
marmite goes for toast they're meant to
be
so in my eyes it only makes sense to
provide an origin story that explains
how the school
came to be the founders are such
enigmatic figures powerful wizards
thought to be more powerful
than modern day wizards and i want to
see that on the big screen
or at the very least the small screen in
my house
hogwarts was founded at some point
during the 10th century it was built
hidden off somewhere in the scottish
highlands
the exact location is never actually
revealed and this was because the 10th
century was a time of hardship for
witches and wizards
during this time every day witches and
wizards were being persecuted by muggles
who were intensely hostile when it came
to witnessing sources of magic
this was a different time a time very
much unlike what we're used to seeing
in the magical world hogwarts was
founded when four 10th century witches
and wizards got together
and decided that they had in the sorting
hat's own words the self-serve yearning
to make the world's best magic school
these founders were gorgeous gryffindor
rowena ravenclaw
salazar slitherin and helga hufflepuff
thus
hogwarts was born not only was this a
time when the school was created but it
was also when the house system was
introduced
gryffindor slytherin ravencore
hufflepuff have you heard of them
wouldn't you like to know what the first
students of the houses were like what
the og of the respective house was like
well make the film the next spin-off
that i want to see made involves none
other than lord voldemort
voldemort intrigues me what an
interesting character and when we see
glimpses of his past
and him at varying stages of his life
i'm only left even more intrigued
now there's a possibility that voldemort
will appear in fantastic beasts
and this could be a very smart move on
warner brothers part if
it's executed well however if he doesn't
show up i still want to see a voldemort
origin story
we know that voldemort turns into a
murderous dark wizard intent on
dominating the wizarding world
and achieving blood purity but what i
want to see the steps in his childhood
that got him to that point
i want to see him at walls orphanage and
witness how he interacted with the other
children
i also want to see him at hogwarts
making friends with the original death
eaters
i want to see him grow up a voldemort
origin story could be a great way of
going back into wizarding history
and doing a character analysis in the
primary antagonist of the harry potter
films
so i'll say it again make the film
another spin-off that i want to see made
involves albus dumbledore
albus was a magical prodigy he was able
to do things with the wand that no one
had seen before
and given that we're only shown the old
age dumbledore i really wanted to see
what he was like as a boy
again the fantastic beast films may
touch on this but i'm not sure how much
and how far back they'll go the premise
of fantastic beasts surrounds the defeat
of gelat grindelwald
who plays quite a large role in
dumbledore's story but what i want to
see
is dumbledore's father being sent to
azkaban and dumbledore's sister being
killed
after being caught in the crossfire of a
three-way jewel involving aberforth
albus and grindelwald i want to see all
of this on screen and the subject matter
is certainly there
so i'll say it one last time make the
film
that's it for today's video i hope you
enjoyed something a little bit different
what spin-offs do you want to see made
if you agree with the ones i mentioned
above then share the video and get the
word out there
do any of these appeal to you more than
the others leave a comment down below
until next time there is plenty to be
learned even from a bad teacher
what not to do how not to be
[Music]
you